Becoming a Hollywood star is hard, but maintaining
the success is even harder.
From former child stars, to one hit wonders,
to total has-beens there are tons of stories
of actors and actresses falling from grace
without much notice.
We are taking a look at some of the most interesting
cases for our list of 10 Popular Actors Who
Vanished Out Of Nowhere!
Enjoy this video and be sure to the subscribe
button to get brand new Screen Rant content,
every single day!
Jack Gleeson
Jack Gleeson is much better known as King
Joffrey from Game Of Thrones AKA the most
hated TV villain in recent memory.
Gleeson was so good in the role that the entire
world truly despised him and when his character
was killed off, fans rejoiced.
While this is actually a testament to Gleeson’s
acting ability, it may have proved too much
for the young actor to handle as he decided
that Hollywood was not for him.
Gleeson returned to school and is now finishing
up his graduate degree.
There is no telling if he will return to the
spotlight any time, but for now he is just
another example of an actor vanishing from
Hollywood.
Jack Nicholson
Jack Nicholson is one of the most respected
actors still alive and his body of work is
as diverse as it is impressive.
Nicholson has been nominated and awarded for
decades for movies like The Shining, The Departed…Oh,
and he was The Joker too!
Lately, we haven’t seen much form Jacky
and the reason why is actually quite sad.
It was reported that Nicholson has stopped
acting because in 2013 he began to realize
that he was no longer able to remember his
lines.
It’s very tough to see such an amazing talent
pulled out of the industry for this reason
and we will always cherish the great performances
that Nicholson has given us!
Macauley Culkin
These days we feel bad for Macaulay Culkin
as the only place his names seems to be showing
up is in lists of child actors who aged terribly.
Culkin was absolutely amazing in the Home
Alone franchise and it truly seemed like he
was going to turn that young success into
a great career.
Unfortunately, like so many others like him,
he got swept up in the fame, money and drugs
and vanished from Hollywood.
Culkin is still remembered fondly by many
so perhaps there is a chance for redemption
for him, but we doubt it.
Amanda Bynes
Amanda Bynes is one of the saddest stories
of a promising young actor fading into obscurity.
As a teenager, Bynes was electric on her variety
show The Amanda Show and in movies like She’s
The Man and Hairspray but since then she really
hasn’t done much.
A few years back, she began publically ranting
on Twitter and it came to light that Amanda
Bynes lives with some pretty challenging mental
illnesses.
These illnesses often begin to emerge in people’s
early twenties so it makes perfect sense when
and why Amanda Bynes disappeared from Hollywood
at exactly that time.
We wish all the best for Bynes and hope she
has a successful comeback if she ever wants
one.
Daniel Day-Lewis
Daniel Day-Lewis is one of the most talented
and awarded actors of our generation.
He doesn’t seem to make a bad movie, but
maybe that is because he really doesn’t
make that many films.
DDL is famous for completely disappearing
from Hollywood between his roles, for example
he has not been in a movie since he played
the titular role in 2012’s Lincoln.
We are guessing that he is just a very picky
guy who only wants to do certain films, but
it’s definitely uncommon for an actor to
follow up an Oscar winning performance with
a 5-year drought.
Daniel Day-Lewis will be appearing in an untitled
2017 film directed by Paul Thomas Anderson,
the guy who made There Will Be Blood.
Johnny Depp
While Johnny Depp hasn’t completely disappeared
from movies (yet), he seems to have disappeared
from good movies over the last few years.
Depp used to be one of the most respected
working actors and was credited with being
able to completely transform into any role.
It seems like he may have lost his mojo as
he has been pumped boring, disappointing and
even creepy performances for years now.
From Willy Wonka to The Tourist to Black Mass,
the actor seems to keep missing the mark.
We’re fans of Depp and we are still hopeful
that he will be able to return to form and
turn in a few more great performances.
Jared Leto
Everyone knows that Jared Leto will be playing
The Joker for years to come in the DCEU but
did you know that there was a time when the
actor actually vanished from Hollywood.
In the early 2000’s the actors played some
amazing roles in movies like American Psycho
and Requiem for a Dream but then in 2009 the
actor seemingly vanished.
Where did he go?
Well Jared Leto was actually focusing his
time and energy on his band 30 Seconds To
Mars during those years and they achieved
some pretty big success.
In 2013, Leto reappeared in impressive fashion
taking home the Academy Award for Best Supporting
Actor in Dallas Buyers Club, pretty impressive
for his first role back in Hollywood.
Tara Reid
Things were a lot different back in 1999,
people were worried about Y2K, TLC had the
number one song in the world and Tara Reid
was a relevant actor.
Reid started in the teen comedy American Pie
and with her looks and talents it seemed like
her career was headed for stardom.
Unfortunately for her, it never really panned
out and she has been constantly struggling
to appear in even the most insignificant roles.
You know your acting career is in big trouble
when your most notable role in the last ten
years comes in 2013’s Sharknado.
Ralph Macchino
Quick, who plays The Karate Kid?
If you said Jaden Smith, you are probably
younger than us and might not know that the
original Karate Kid from the 1984 film was
actually played by Ralph Macchino.
Ralph was amazing in the role and everyone
predicted that his career would skyrocket.
Unfortunately, Macchino is just one on the
long list of child actors whose careers have
tanked after their early success.
Over the years Macchino has made the odd appearance
in obscure shows and movies, but nothing really
notable.
For some funny moments of people making fun
of Ralph Macchino’s career, check out the
2016 Comedy Central Roast of Rob Lowe.
Lindsay Lohan
Every time Lindsay Lohan attempted to make
a comeback to the Hollywood Spotlight, it
goes poorly.
It’s too bad because as a young actor she
was really great in movies like The Parent
Trap, Freaky Friday and Mean Girls.
Lohan has famously gotten into a lot of trouble
with the law and the once beautiful actress
is definitely looking worse these days.
We’re not completely ruling out a comeback
for Lohan, but until she figures things out
a little better with herself, we think its
bet that she stays vanished.
So there’s our list of 10 popular actors
who totally vanished from Hollywood out of
nowhere.
Which one of these actors was your favorite?
What other famous stars disappeared out of
nowhere?
Let us know what you think in the comments
section below and be sure to subscribe to
our channel for more fun videos – like this
one!